Tom Karen joining us from NBC sports
Boston here the day after the Patriots
win their 6th Superbowl championship on
the Rich Eisen show how are you Tom I'm
good too and I'm sure you got a question
lined up but I say to you - on Friday
you know that's one thing that really
opened my eyes rich was when Shawn
McVeigh said to Serena Williams who was
the NFC pool reporter we just had you
know background music here in practice
because we don't figure it's gonna be
real loud and it's just not gonna be
like it was against New Orleans since a
neutral site and I said what is he
talking about there's not going to be
any LA fans there it's a dome people get
noisy in these things anyway 2013 you
saw eight Manning take a safety at the
outset of a game in the Super Bowl and
an outdoor stadium I just thought that
that was incredibly short-sighted
decision by him and you know I said
terrific coach and I think that the cut
of his jib is one that I like me too but
I also think that he had a tough tough
day well I mean we had Jeff Schwartz on
an hour one and he agreed that he was
out coached but look McVeigh is a
special special person and coach and I'm
not gonna throw the baby out with the
super bowl bathwater that everybody's
just wanna get the 66 year old guy who's
coaching in his he just wanted eight
crazy it's a Super Bowl it's nuts
so what I'll ask you again I may have
asked you before what does he do that
that no other coaches are able to do as
well let's put it that way I mean what
what does Belichick do with his staff
with the players that makes it work I
think I have a good answer for you and
Kevin Clarkson the ringer wrote a good
story about it - what more than anything
else
differentiates the Patriots from every
other team is they make themselves
adaptable their system is no system it
is whatever it needs to be so that's why
sometimes over the course of the season
it takes a long time for the team to
develop and that's why sometimes they
can solicit players
not height weight speed demons that
everybody else jumps off that jumps off
the page for reals why does it keep
getting guys from Rutgers because
there's a certain style of player who
has to have a level of trust ability
maturity and intelligence and not saying
that Rutgers is a you know boatload of
those guys but Greg Schiano and his son
Steven were both able sign off on them
as guys who were smart and could adapt
so you get those smart and adaptable
guys and you change its excuse me goes
on and change and change and you change
Dante Hightower you know played for
Sabin and he's the smartest player that
you know Kirby smart ever recruited when
he was at Alabama and you put all these
guys together and you put Tom Brady in
there and you say okay we're gonna
change every week it's gonna suck
because it's gonna be a lot harder for
you than everybody else the league but
what's gonna happen is by the end of the
year you're not going to know if you're
the opposing coach your team just what
we're going to be on that day so that's
my best definition yeah Geoff Schwartz
told us as well in a previous appearance
here is that was that with the Giants
going against him that they prepared for
three different looks and the one that
they thought they would see the least
they saw the most and it really caught
them flat-footed
a little bit and it's just really
remarkable in that and then Edelman
being the MVP is kind of perfect in a
way and I know he's sat for four weeks
for for peds but what he is is a guy who
is you want to talk about DAP table I
mean the guy had I do believe one catch
in college he came in as a seventh round
quarterback and now only Jerry Rice has
more playoff yards receiving than
Edelman and it's gonna be Edelman Brady
to Edelman maybe when the dynasty is all
over that will be the three words that
most fans will refer to even more maybe
Brady to Gronk Tom would you agree with
that or no yeah I would because you know
Brady is certainly the engine but I
think that Edelman is the oil for the
engine doesn't work without him we saw
it in 2015 when Edelman broke his foot
team was ten and oh he breaks foot in
New York that team was nasty that could
have been eight and undefeated
team and if you remember we're talking
about that one settlement went down they
went two and four down the stretch and
he came back for the playoffs but he was
diminished
he is really unique in that his
toughness Welker was brilliant he was a
tough player but he wore down the season
went along because he wasn't quite as
big as Edelman who's not a big guy but
is solidly built and he really wasn't as
elusive as Edelman is either just a
great player Welker was but there's
different things that that Edelman does
then then Welker difference in Amendola
and I think that we still have a hard
time the same way with Edelman that we
did with Brady always people nationally
do it's a system it's a system it's a
system anyone could do it well if anyone
could do it rich why doesn't everybody
do it it's like that old line right from
league of their own if it was easy
everyone would do it it's it's it's
crazy Tom so let's turn the page here a
little bit did Gronk just play his last
game renewing what do you think I really
feel like he did hey I've talked to him
a couple times in the last couple of
weeks and especially on Wednesday I
asked him about his enjoyment level in
2018 and he veered off and started
talking about how you know we in the
media especially locally we put him on
the couch every single week and say
what's the matter with Quran how's he
feeling and we would often weigh in and
say he doesn't seem like himself he
seems down he goes people don't
understand how many collisions we take
on Sunday and how much abuse we put
ourselves through and our brain doesn't
want us to do that and that mental part
is the most difficult thing I saw him in
the locker room last night
he's got his shoulder pads and Jersey
still on he's got his game pants off so
we stand there in his underwear and he's
pressing on his thigh and it was huge
and he goes come here look at this touch
this
okay I'll touch it was oh and rich like
twice the size of a normal large human
squad and as so what's gonna happen with
that because it'll be black and blue and
red tomorrow I can't really walk right
now but at least I don't have to be
ready for practice on Wednesday
at least I don't have to get ready for a
game because that would be the
expectation okay Rob your thighs swollen
up to twice it's normal size how do what
do you think you'll be able to do this
week I think that's really where it's
gotten to him buddy
and so Brady what happens with him here
because it's it's his world we're just
paying rent and and I mean he's got to
feel great just because of obviously
he's now won as many championships as
Michael Jordan I mean that's the
comparison that's being made today also
whatever might have been going on behind
the scenes about Jimmy G and whatever
quote that you know Ian O'Connor put in
his book from a an unnamed member of the
staff from a couple years ago basically
intimating that Brady's a system
quarterback I mean he just won is a 41
year old guy and then there's the
photograph that we saw today from
getting images of him holding up the
Lombardi Trophy with the reflection of
his daughter in his arms who's now old
enough to be able to remember these
moments when Daddy won the Super Bowl so
he's just gonna keep going here one
would think what happens but the things
remain the things that make Belichick
great are the things that make this a
situation where bills not going to stand
patty 66 years old he's got a million
friends in the college game he wants to
continue to evolve and being with a 41
soon to be 42 year old quarterback word
I have this what happened last night
regardless what happens for the last 17
years don't once the next thing and when
they do sit down the Kraft spoke to us
on NBC Sports Boston on Tuesday and sat
down with us and kind of gave assurances
that you'll talk to us a training camp
because there's a Brady he's never gone
into the walk year of his contract
Johnson said talk to me in training camp
it's not it's not the end of it's not
just walk here yet
so they're assured that they're gonna
get something done but still making Bill
Belichick say okay we're gonna spend 90
million dollars guaranteed for instance
on Tom Brady for the next three years as
he's 42 43 and 44 what are we doing I
guarantee you that's how we would feel
about it and we'll feel about it
so that to me is where
everything resurfaces they get to the
crescendo they had this but then the
realities are going to hit to that Tom
Braden doesn't have a contract
Bronks gonna go someplace else Julian's
33 the afterglow I think will fade a
little bit into some of the realities
and things they have to face then the
last one for year then Tom what is it
gonna be their draft priority sitting
there 32nd overall they maybe move up
and get the quarterback for the future
or stay put and get Brady a nice shiny
new wide receiver toy or what do you
think boys they got to get up a tight
end because if Gronk leaves you only
have Dwayne Allen and Jacob Hollister on
the roster so this is a tight end based
offense not gonna find a grunt just
hanging around unless you can find
another one in the second round and the
wide receiver depths you know Phillip
Dorsett and Chris Hogan between them
were targeted
well none for Oh none for Dorsett six
for hug it didn't catch any they need to
get better skill position players around
Brady because what they did on the
ground and defensively kind of masked a
little bit of its Brady a 41 year old
throwing to a 33 year old and a broke a
29 year old Tommy the best man thanks
for taking the time I know you've been
away from your family for a while so
we'll chat again real shoot real real
shortly okay okay buddy great week great
work out of you and I'm always happy to
come on and thanks for thinking of me
Joey's that's Tom Torre the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience